another video another day huh look at
that just birds just chirping outside
here listen to him shut the [ __ ] up all
right
[Music]
hey what is going on YouTube
happy quarantine so it turns out that
Los Angeles is officially on lockdown
you want to know why is because some of
you don'ts out there still wanted to
party out there like it's Armageddon you
bacterial butt [ __ ] [ __ ] so
basically what the government is saying
is that since you don't want to play
pack the roof they ain't gon be no roof
what does that sound like what Scarface
in Tagalog versus say hello to my little
friend Ana correct I'll tell you this
right now I don't know how you
extroverts are surviving because I'm
typically an introvert and even then I
need some socializing I've heard you
could tell people are dying for some
type of socialization just based on
what's on your insta story and social
media no tell me why some of our friends
who clown on social media clown on
people who do insist or ease are
suddenly all about that social media
life it's a quarantine [ __ ] not a life
sentence I suddenly drop in their jobs
and finding their passions like mr. Joe
dumbass down Chris Brown you ain't [ __ ]
over here locking to finding a passion
for rapping out of nowhere
I was poppin y'all was good yo Instagram
ha it's your boy squirt squirt talking
about that y'all I know y'all been DMing
me you know talking about your when
you're gonna drop that next hot single
well I got it for you real quick but to
give you all that sample real quick you
feeling this track right here is called
dick is not an option dick is not an
option
cuz I [ __ ] with you but I ain't [ __ ]
with you like dat doe cuz that's gay but
I'm okay with it because the I don't you
know cuz you eat quality LGBTQ coming to
a Santa Monica Boulevard near you you
feel me huh you like hip hop you like
hip hop
yeah suddenly you 2pac Shaq ur [ __ ]
punch yourself we honestly take for
granted a lot of the everyday luxuries
that are afforded to us because there
really hasn't been
something like this to really force our
perspective right if anything the
positive thing that's coming from this
epidemic is really teaching us how we
should be grateful for the things that
we have forces you guys have any idea
how crazy this is like said if I stop
doing these videos because these videos
used to give me depression but now my
source of sadness it's the only thing
keeping me sane what the [ __ ] I do this
for you [ __ ] are mine and on
top of that let me tell you something
I'm stuck here with my girlfriend every
day I wake up she's there I'm eating
she's there I'm pooping she's there now
I'm the man of this house man King Kong
ain't got King Kong ain't got [ __ ] on me
I'm stuck here with my girlfriend all
day yay she's ignore the [ __ ] nothing
that's going on here
spot that be so after the last video we
have some interesting comments from some
dumb people and today I got time to
respond to some of them you know why cuz
I got time someone wrote and they
deleted this comment basically what they
were saying is that we are blowing this
whole koban situation out of proportion
that we should all start hanging out
with their friends and family again
because our bodies will fight off the
natural disease with our natural
antibodies what is it with people in
this country that don't understand that
this whole situation is not just about
you yes there are people who are
asymptomatic there are people who are
going to get this that aren't going to
survive this but that's not the [ __ ]
point one is there is a reason why we're
trying to stop the spread of this virus
because the virus is spreading at a very
very alarming rate we do stupid
comparisons to the flu because yes the
flu has killed more people than the
corona virus but you also have to
realize how long the corona virus has
been around from what I've read and what
I've heard from people who are
physicians is that this virus is in its
infancy stages so we don't know what
this is going to mutate into that we
need a vaccine what are you people
saying oh we had the plague and we all
survived that [ __ ] don't play killed
hella people you [ __ ] are the
apple cider and blueberries up my [ __ ]
to cure AIDS people aren't you if you
have diarrhea to stick this crystal up
your ass that Bo a larger chakras listen
at the end of the day I understand there
is this massive
stereo going on people buying out toilet
paper bottled waters and [ __ ] you
[ __ ] maniacs what do you do you have
tap water [ __ ] the tap water is just as
clean Oh suddenly now you too fancy for
tap water oh my bad suddenly tap water
isn't good enough for you [ __ ] you eat
ass you over here in quarantine eating
booty and all sudden tap waters too for
you now stop hoarding food stop hoarding
toilet paper and ridiculous amounts
relax we'll all get through this
together we shall prevail well guys
happy quarantine and I'll see you all
next time huh what love you